hello welcome back to GameSpot's game of
year coverage for 2015 you are watching
the platform report cards really
Microsoft Xbox one thank you so much for
joining me and the Alexa and Justin hey
world Justin first of all xbox one
lagging behind in sales still lagging
behind in overall sales I mean when we
look at it month-on-month the
PlayStation has had a really strong year
but that doesn't mean that the Xbox has
had a failure of year like that I think
that's the way a lot of people couch it
is that well because it's in second
place it's obviously a failure but it's
not it's still selling better than the
xbox 360 did which was a ridiculously
popular and successful non soul and when
you especially when you look towards the
end of this year maybe they had a slow
start Microsoft famously had to reverse
a lot of policies but those have I think
paid off towards the end of this year
not only a lower price point with great
bundles the Xbox has started out selling
the PlayStation again month on month of
course it'll take a while to catch up
how to run a great month in October a
lot of it down to selling in bundles as
well hmm and the bundles are just a
great way to couch the xbox one and
especially towards the end of this year
when sony has had some great games
they've had some great deals but they
haven't had a lot of exclusive titles at
the end of this year whereas xbox that's
been their biggest strength games like
rise of the Tomb Raider sure it's not
going to be exclusive forever but being
able to couch that is like here's our
console exclusive Raeleen it's your halo
5 like they've had a great holiday of
really fun titles yeah let's talk about
some of those games first of all rise of
the Tomb Raider Alexa I wonderful the
first game is great yeah interesting
sort of old-school type of excusive
gamer you know grabbing a an established
franchise especially strange i got 2nd
game in and much to the chagrin of
playstation 4 owner is it ended up being
pretty great oh yeah like like the salt
is very strong with ps4 voters right now
because every time I tweet about tomb
raider my mentions are filmed with mike
wagon a way to hear so good i think it
is the best the best exclusive barring
or best Triple A exclusive on that
console right now it is just phenomenal
the level design is phenomenal the
script is great it's not like it doesn't
hold your hand and it gives you a lot of
opportunities to sort of do things as
you would like to do them as you want to
complete missions you can
go make a bomb or you can like sneak
around and it's just it's just so great
and that's obviously a series that is a
you know sort of a regular third-party
exclusive and also a great year for
first party games or second party games
at microsoft xbox one games alabama and
your massive fan of cars on Forza this
year proved to make another great game
for you you know any force games are on
xbox one's there's three for two games
already on xbox one Microsoft has done
this thing where they're like we're
gonna make a new game every year for you
they're like they're like servicing me
I'm like yes bring it bring it to me
more likely to air your car yourself my
car is in the shop and I'm getting the
service no but it's like that they're
awesome at this like thing where they're
like all right we're gonna have really
good Studios work on these leapfrog
games like Call of Duty did it yeah for
a long time there and they're still
doing with like five studios now or
whatever but it's like yeah forts of
five was a good start what's a verizon
blew everybody away cuz it was
incredible 426 is a way better for 25
you're not getting totally what no i
mean it's still like super good it's so
comprehensive hmm so like i'm super
happy with the xbox one as far as as
force' goes yeah so what about you then
I guess sohail ok mad weird honor we had
a master chief collection last year
which obviously had a lot of problem led
me of issues especially technically and
any halo 5 fans on the couch we got a
lot of people in the office who play
clearly well master chief collection had
a rocky start but I think it's totally
redeemed itself this year maybe it was a
little bit overreaching and they should
have just started with rich single
player experience which was great like
the single player experience has been
great and now introducing these
multiplayer aspects later and now i
think it's come full circle and halo 5
is a great extension of that maybe it's
not i think destiny has really stolen a
lot of the thunder from you but it's
still a really strong great narrative
experience i would disagree on that i
think that that halos i like the war
zone i think war zone is really
refreshed yes multiplayer but that
narrative was just it was just a mess
and i kind of forgot like it doesn't
have what pulled me into previous games
like it doesn't have doesn't have that
spark it sort of done weird things with
master chief and I think it's sort of i
think it's very it's very device yeah a
lot of people player you're right a very
divisive a lot of people say that you
know it feels very much like the middle
part of a trilogy and it sort of does
really satisfy either
stepping away from the triple-a stuff
obviously one of the things we saw which
people are very very happy about was
rare replay which is rare having their
sort of identity given back to them and
you know you can finally play a bunch of
those or classic games on the Xbox one
again and in terms of I guess you know
there haven't been that many exclusives
in terms of the indie stuff this year
across the board and this is a console
exclusive or in the Black Forest commit
you know it feels like it's incredible
thinking came out this year
fantastically phenomenal like where did
that come from they remember when they
announced they were like oh this is
super cute and then you'd get it and
it's like here's a really sad story run
away from the lava club with the bow and
do it now you have to go you can't turn
back it's so perfect and we saw a lot of
HD games we talked a lot about them
we're going to talk about a lot them a
lot more when it comes to Sony's console
as well we're gonna get Gears of War for
next year Gears of for give you name it
and gears of war HD came in as well
earlier this year and what do you think
about that Justin dipping back two
franchises had already seen another all
together that old oh it's it seemed like
a smarter thing I think when when they
started developing these titles so the
behemoth and castle crashers was one we
saw an HD remake of as well and I think
they started these near the beginning of
the xbox one's life cycle and that's
something we're good to see a lot less
because of backwards compatibility like
the Xbox one is something that's going
to be able to play xbox 360 games ensure
this is a great way to revisit some
titles that maybe didn't age as well
Gears of War in particular is good but
the HD version looks so much better they
were able to to just fix the visual
problems that the game had and I love
being able to revisit who especially
when that team is able to revisit their
games and make it better but at the same
time like it's not that old I'd rather
just pick it put in my xbox 360 disc
because I still have it i can just pop
it in there or maybe you have it
digitally but we're still gonna be able
to do that so that's not that a problem
that's no problem whenever the new
consoles come and we sort of have to you
know pick your poison right off the bat
you have to say especially with when it
comes to Sony and Microsoft all right
I'm going to go PlayStation this time
I'm gonna go with microscopes this time
and Andy I know you're one of the people
in the office who immediately went for
the xbox probably because of your love
of games like Forza and I know you've
gotten the PlayStation 4 this year where
does the xbox one lie in your in your
living room right now is there something
you you play most exclusives on you want
an interesting fact about the xbox one
that's cool it operates Wi-Fi on the 5
gigahertz band which seems like such a
nerdy like things to talk about the
places for it does not do this yeah um
and it actually I live in the situation
we're like there's so much Wi-Fi in my
apartment building yeah that I need that
five-year hurts band really to actually
get a good signal and a fast it boots
might be like so much faster because
there's less noise on that band so the
xbox one can connect to my router and
it's so i use it for everything he's for
entertainment and so when i go through
for like HBO and Netflix and now yeah
netflix and so it's actually doing its
thing as its inner as my one yeah it is
it is my info one yeah you know what i
mean like so and i do like the
playstation 4 as a gaming system maybe
like a little bit more hmm but it
doesn't have forza and it doesn't have
the tribe records ban does that to
matter which i'll probably play yeah it
seems like this year might be you know
it wasn't a fantastic year for the xbox
one obviously a lot of you know people
saying it's may be sold half as many the
ps4 across both their lifetimes but it
does seem like you know especially and
talk with the last three months like
perhaps they set themselves up for a
much better 20 16 2016 is going to be
really interesting especially like as a
pc gamer myself like primarily my
favorite games are on pc and xbox one is
is microsoft like they are a pc company
how do they come together with these
things and it feels like the things that
they ignored with xbox 360 and games for
windows all that is being thrown out the
window for Windows 10 yeah and bringing
those things together and that hasn't
been fully realized yet but the promise
of not only being able to play your xbox
one games on your PC but being able to
eventually play PC games on your xbox
one like that's an awesome future for
someone like me do you think they'll end
up going down that line and nightly that
it was like they can like I think that
is going to be full merge like first
we're going to have more xbox one xbox
one games on your pc I went already you
can access your friends list and do lots
of things and there are certain specific
games that work on them that Xbox app is
pretty much ingrained in the end Oh Stan
and eventually I think it's going to be
full integration I mean if you know
we're looking at things like you know
steam boxes and everyone else trying to
get that pc in the living room if you've
already got a pc
in the living room why not let it be a
PC it's down you know I'm price as well
like you can get one for about 350 bucks
those bundles are selling as well hand
over fist and which really speaks to a
crowd of people who want to buy a
console and get as many games for it as
possible getting the value and the value
is so important anybody have a connect
did you get a connect with your xbox I
still get you the voice command yes
they're valuable but there's something
nice but stumbling home at the end of
day and just being like xbox turn on and
it's a beautiful exhale exit greets me
like I it still works I still use it
yeah it's pretty good but you know
there's no case for it no no there are
not any any more games for ya now it's
done dead dead technology I mean Phil
Spencer came in and just cleaned house
yes as far as and he's working so hard
to like impress us which I love like I
haven't seen Microsoft have to do this
and there and the fact that they have
because they screwed up so bad is it out
of awesome for us for gamers because
they're they're like please please xbox
360 backs for compatibility they're like
okay features left right they give us
this controller that's incredible I mean
cause it costs a lot of money haha but
like dude they're doing stuff that's
like I don't know definitely turning
court you know it takes a lot of time to
make a ship like this you know turn
around completely yeah 2015 sort of
pointing in the right direction so
looking forward to next year I thank you
all for coming on and talking to me
about xbox one I thank to everyone who's
been watching our game of the year
coverage let us know what you think
about the xbox one and all your other
consoles you have at home what's your
favorite and were you a playstation
owner it's looking towards xbox one now
because if tomb raider were you an OG
xbox fine what did you think of 2015 let
us know in the comments below
you